explaining to people that they can
actually learn skills just like I said
the example I always use is playing
guitar or shooting baskets in basketball
like you can't just pick up a basketball
and beat think you can make free throws
it's like not happening you can't pick
up a guitar and just think you're gonna
be able to play you it's skill and
Leadership is the same way and are there
some people that have a little bit of a
tendency that have better hand-eye
coordination then they're gonna be able
to pick up basketball a little bit
quicker yeah are there people that have
a certain ability to recognize different
notes when they hear them yeah that's an
actual thing you can be born with but
regardless you still need to learn the
skills in order to get good at and
leadership's the same way you're going
to have some natural propensity for it
there's going to be some parts of it
you'll be good at there's going to be
some parts you'll suck at take advantage
of the ones you're good at you work on
the ones you're not but it's definitely
everyone can get better unless they're a
person that says I already know
everything